[Music]
on America's greatest makers 24 teams of
inventors compete for a 1 million dollar
prize is that right yes sir okay
and there's one caveat you have to use
in your invention something that Intel
makes called the Curie module chips that
right yes sir all right explain what the
curing module chip is so I've actually
got one here to show you okay but the
Curie module is this amazing chip made
by Intel mm-hmm it packs a lot of things
which I know nothing about technology so
black chip okay
I even I know big black chip right there
okay this chip what's so great about
this chip it's amazing so it's got a
bunch of things integrated into it like
an accelerometer and a gyroscope which
helps us track motion let's go
I insist on those than any chip I use
when I invent and so it's got both of
those and and this is a very valuable
chip for you to use in the invention
that you guys came up with absolutely
yes it is now you could come up with
anything you want your invention is
called the Newton and it addresses a
really big hot topic story in the news
which is concussions in sports yes sir
yep all right you can tell me now more
what are you hurt
I love hey just were like yes sir good
night everybody
we just fade the black know this is a
huge topic not just in the pros but also
in youth sports sure okay what is this
work how does it work so the Newton is a
device that has the Intel theory module
in it used and it is placed in the back
of the players head and in real time
athletic trainers and coaches will get
notifications as large impacts occur on
their head you're saying that you you
put this on somewhere on the head of the
athlete correct and that's going to
monitor the severity of the blow that
the athlete just took yep and then
that's gonna show up on the coaches what
I said bone or for Apple watch yeah this
is a serious topic because there are a
lot of a lot of my friends won't let
their kids play football you know that's
that's a big that's a big deal they
won't let their kids play football and
people are worried about it's apparently
it's not just the first hit that you
take for a concussion it's the second
one is that right yep so secondary
impact syndrome is when you actually
take a hit that is concussive and you go
back on the fields the
coach my trainer might miss that hit if
you take another concussive blow you
could get long-term brain damage or even
death right okay so this is good because
they can see that you've taken the first
one and then prevent the second one who
are happening by benching you exactly
all right let's see how the Newton works
we have I think this is either a
demonstration or a huge coincidence that
this is behind us right now tell us what
this what we're gonna see here alright
so I am going to this is our dummy
Sir Isaac Conan nope Newton okay we're
gonna face on this this guy who's asking
for a concussion
we're Nam he seems very angry about
something all right so where does it go
it doesn't go on the helmet no it goes
inside the helmet on a skull cap or a
headband and it just docks right in okay
like so okay and and then you know
player puts his helmet on over that over
that where's this underneath and then if
the player you say gets a concussion or
a blow to the head this will register
yeah this is what the coder hopes say
this is what the coach will see so right
now you're looking at the roster of the
football team okay all right these are
all I see just made up these are names
of your friends or something
Isaac Newton yeah we know Isaac Newton I
didn't do that and then it's the rest of
our team actually yeah oh man should
great linemen all right I will now
create what I think is a concussive
impact using this machine well you ready
on three one two three okay a player in
orange just slammed headfirst is our
player so notification pops up I can
click into the player's profile okay I
can take a look at the hit as we can see
it registered a frontal hit and you can
actually replay the hit throughout the
course of the impact so that's how it
works and so these are all the different
hits that say the players taken to of
the game and a big exactly spike on the
back way and that's kind of what
differentiates us as we can track that
history over time okay does it also have
GPA things like that in there
maybe one day what one day you can have
a whole profile of the player just took
a hit and not that smart to begin with
would it register if I hit him on the
side of the head cuz with one of these
is the O'Brien haymaker right here let's
see what you got going why are you
laughing at that
I'm a large fellow with a lethal blow
alright okay I don't need that part
right here I'm just gonna use this
myself oh that could kill me if I got
here
and you guys don't look like you're
really on your a-game all right I'll
just be back here ready all right there
you go why did they get last hey gave
him a concussion that was me really
trying to is that gonna Wow look at that
move that aside not one more try amateur
oh man hey how did that hello anything
any improvement there
[Applause]
their God say come down here all of a
sudden good alright well I prove nothing
except maybe the safest thing you can do
is have me hit your child don't let them
play football but let Conan take a swing
at them any day because apparently that
registers the same amount is a soft cool
spring breeze
you